let's go next to our caller from the
2:01 area code who's calling today from
201 hey David it's Elias Matthews from
Buffalo New York
hey Elias what's going on nothing much
so normally I would ask questions but I
have two questions and I don't want to
take up too much of your time so I'm
just gonna ask would you rather at me
ask the medicare-for-all question or a
question about the mentally ill I'll let
you pick you give me the Medicare
question okay so if Bernie does become
president how would you implement
Medicare for all could he do it through
executive order No how would it go about
doing so well he would have to do it by
getting the House and Senate to pass it
and this is going to be one of the
difficulties I have to be careful
because my audience becomes furious with
me when I say that it's actually going
to be way tougher than almost anyone on
the Left is willing to admit but no no
it's not going to be executive order
it's gonna have to be by actually
getting the House and Senate to agree
and that will likely require some
negotiation okay do you think that we
should negotiate for like a public
option or do you think that we should
definitely get Medicare for all do you
think we should I don't know what like
what we would negotiate with is what I'm
saying yeah you don't know what where we
where the negotiation might end up I am
NOT going so if I say now that we should
settle for something less then I will be
accused of being defeatist
so what I think should happen is Bernie
should campaign on what his ideal policy
is if people like that ideal policy they
should vote for Bernie
if Bernie's president at that point
given whatever House and Senate there is
Bernie can start the process of trying
to get Medicare for all once we
determine what the opposition is to it
then negotiations can take place but I
think to prejudge where the negotiations
will end up now doesn't really gonna go
all right cool thank you may ask another
quick question sure uh how do you decide
which calls become your videos
all of them do we don't decide we just
put did they all do oh they all do yeah
okay you just all do okay cool
yeah all right have a good day David
keep up the good work your stuff is
great all right Thank You Allah from
Buffalo elias from buffalo absolutely
killing it